بالنسبة للصاروخ الذي سقط
على الأراضي السعودية ، فهو
صاروخ إيراني أطلقه حزب الله
من منطقة يحتلها الحوثيون
في اليمن ، يشبه الصاروخ إلى حد بعيد
صاروخ أطلق في تموز / يوليو الماضي
على بلدة يان بوي التي صنع فيها.
إيران تم تفكيكها وتهريبها
إلى أجزاء في اليمن وتم
تجميعها في اليمن من قبل عناصر من
الحرس الثوري ومن
حزب الله ثم تم إطلاقها
ضد المملكة العربية السعودية
وهذا ما حدث نحن نعتبره عملاً
حربياً لا تستطيع إيران إطلاق الصواريخ.  في
المدن والبلدات السعودية ونتوقع منا عدم اتخاذ
خطوات في إيران بموجب
المادة 51 من ميثاق الأمم المتحدة من ميثاق الأمم المتحدة
، فلا يمكن للإيرانيين الجلوس هناك
والتدخل في
شؤون دول المنطقة سواء في
لبنان سواء في اليمن أو في اليمن.
سوريا داخل العراق سواء في البحرين
وتتوقع الحصول على تصريح مرور مجاني ، فأنت
تصف هذا بأنه عمل حرب ليس
عملاً حربياً محتملاً ولكنه عمل حربي
يصحح كيف  إنه
عمل عدائي للغاية ، وهذه ليست المرة الأولى التي يتم فيها إطلاق
صواريخ على المملكة
العربية السعودية صواريخ إيرانية / من قبل
وكلاء إيران من الحوثيين وما هي
إعانات حزب الله التي يقدمونها
للحرس الثوري الإيراني ، هل لدينا أن
لدينا  صاروخ الألمنيوم جاء من
إيران وأنظمة التوجيه من
إيران والكابلات عليها حروف إيرانية.
القوارب الانتحارية التي استخدمها الحوثيون
في اليمن إيرانية وأجهزة الكمبيوتر بها
حروف إيرانية على لوحات مفاتيحها هي
مقر
التحالف الداعم.  عقدت الحكومة الرقمية
في اليمن يوم أمس
إيجازًا صحفيًا موسعًا
قدموا فيه كل هذه الأدلة ولا
شك في أن هذه الصواريخ وهذه
القوارب الانتحارية جاءت من العراق من خلال وصف
هذا العمل بأنه عمل حرب
ما نية المملكة العربية السعودية تجاهه وأقول
ذلك.  اعتدى الإيرانيون
على السعودية حيث
أطلقت
إيران أكثر من مرة صاروخ إيراني على السعودية  وكلاء ما
تسمونه هذا وبالتالي
انتهك الإيرانيون ميثاق الأمم المتحدة ،
انتهك الإيرانيون القانون الدولي من خلال
استهداف والسماح لوكلائهم
باستهداف المدنيين في المملكة العربية السعودية
وقلنا إننا نحتفظ بالحق في
الرد بالطريقة المناسبة على
الوقت المناسب